[Applause]
always dreamed about having my own show
but to be a hit i have to appeal to
everyone and that's what i set out to do
take a look
the first step on my quest for ratings
goal was maggot and associates the most
prestigious tv research firm in town in
order to get the biggest audience you
can you're going to want to make sure
the show doesn't exclude any one portion
of the population i think i got the
black and hispanic viewers down pack you
know but how do i get white viewers like
what's some things white people really
like watching anything with a southern
theme or southern setting has been
ratings gold
there's here comes honey boo boo my
problem with that show is she's a white
girl to act black
you know me personally just give me a
straight white girl i don't want a white
girl with attitude that's defeats the
whole purpose of having a white girl
right
like what kind of dog does white people
like uh a labrador retriever labrador
labrador retriever what type of
fabric do white people like white people
dig corduroy corduroy there we go
what type of cereal do white people like
granola
grape nuts
all the better if it's organic
that [ __ ] is expensive
so like this show ain't got that budget
to go buy some organic cereal
we can go
mix some frosty flakes and put some
almonds in it i think that would
definitely help out okay i would do that
then
so what do you like
i love to play tennis i'm really into
hiking throw on the backpack and some
boots go out for you know good six hour
hike in the morning we see black people
don't get off and hiking too much like
that you know we don't
wanna be wanna mess our shoes up like
that
you ever dated a black girl i have not
wow
[Laughter]
what should i stay away from if i'm
trying to get a white audience
white people like ski masks i think
white people like ski masks when they're
wearing them on the slopes in vermont
but not so much when a black person is
wearing one really maybe in an adt
commercial
adt you you mean the home alarm system
he's a racist
and he's also a genius when it comes to
white people because he just told me
everything i need to get white viewers
this summer on tbs comedy is about to
get a little bit lighter
hello i know what you're thinking is
this a adt commercial it's not
but it is a commercial for my new show
dion cole's black box on tbs
here you go we got hiking boots peanut
butter made out of weird [ __ ] and that
guy from jeopardy my show has everything
you all love help me make it a hit
hey what'd you say freedom you like
black box too of course you do freedom
dion cole's black box
it's gonna be better than this bowl of
organic granola
dion coal just the right amount of black
[Applause]